let's go to our next caller from the
five one three area code caller from
five one three
welcome who's this hi David this is
Chris from Cincinnati how are you doing
good what's on your mind today um
another woman just came for your
breaking up you said another woman just
came forward is that what you said yes
sorry another woman came forward
accusations against Brett Kavanaugh and
she is represented by Michael avenatti
and I was wondering if you thought if
avenatti plays in a part in preventing
Cavanaugh and being appointed to the
court if it could legitimize his
candidacy to be the Democratic nominee
in 2020 I don't see avenatti as being
the Democratic nominee full stop right I
mean if the guy cures cancer you know
but maybe but I just don't think that
he's going to be the nominee I think
he's doing a tremendously good job of
raising his profile I do find something
about the guy off-putting although I
completely support the specifics of what
he's doing here with his work with these
accusers of Brett Kavanaugh but I don't
think he's going to be the Democratic
nominee but I also didn't think Trump
would be President so Who am I
yeah I don't know there are publican
bases more you know goofy about to that
point with like you know Reagan and
Trump but I don't know crazier things
have happened
I wanted to get your take crazier things
have happened and one of them is in the
Oval Office right now you're absolutely
right about that Chris thanks for the
call great to hear from folks in in Ohio
we love Ohio that's we love every state
don't even when they vote for Trump yeah
we still love the state we still love
most of the people in the state sure
absolutely